des mesures qui ont été décidées le
premier ministre l'a dit avec la
profession donc on s'attendait un petit
peu ces mesures elles sont déjà presque
installés un peu partout
la difficulté c'est qu'effectivement la
distance entre les tables va dans
certains établissements réduire à avoir
un impact sur le nombre de clients que
pourront accueillir les restaurateurs
alors en france comme dans le monde la
pandémie de coronavirus a marqué un
véritable coup d'arrêt pour le secteur
du tourisme
c'était 7,4 pour cent du pib en 2010 8,2
millions d'emplois pour le sauver le
premier ministre a annoncé le 14 mars
dernier un plan d'urgence de 18
milliards d'euros est ce que ça vous
semble suffisant alors ça n'est pas
suffisant parce que la reprise va être
extrêmement progressive
on le voit sur les mesures qui a annoncé
tout à l'heure le premier ministre les
déplacements vers les autres mers va
être contrainte restreinte avec des
14èmes donc ça veut dire qu'on n'aura
pas beaucoup de clients
si rien ne change pour cet été j'ai peur
qu'on ait un frein aussi parce que la
consommation de nos visiteurs va changer
prendre l'avion est une difficulté pour
certains
donc ça va changer le modèle économique
donc nous aurons besoin de ces mesures
annoncées mais pour un temps plus long
nous souhaiterions que toutes les
mesures aille beaucoup plus loin mars
2021 voir la fin de l'année 2021 parce
que le retour à la normale ne se fera
pas à notre avis avant 2022 j'imagine
que vous mènerez des négociations en ce
sens avec le gouvernement nos demandes
sont déjà partis avec l'ensemble des
groupement hôtelier de des outre-mer
très bien on suivra cela de près on
annonce près de 30% des entreprises qui
risquent la faillite ou le dépôt de
bilan dans le tourisme et de nombreux
professionnels n'envisagent pas
d'embellie pour ce secteur avant 2022
est ce que vous partagez cette analyse
notamment pour nous en martinique
oui tout à fait alors quand on parle de
taux risquent effectivement on regarde
la restauration l'hôtellerie mais il ya
en martinique
nombre d'entreprises qui travaillent
avec le tourisme même des entreprises
qui sont pas à vocation conneries sic
exemple la location de voiture fait 95 %
de son chiffre d'affaires avec les
touristes
les vendeurs à sainte-anne travail
forcément avec les touristes
les vendeurs les commerçants je veux
dire les excursion nautique les
excursions terrestre les agences de
voyages tous tout ça c'est de les taxis
tout ça c'est du monde du tourisme et
tous ceux là vont vont subir les
conséquences de cette restriction de
tourisme en martinique